and now I'm fully equipped to
start working one more day, let's
see the patients talk to my colleagues,
go through the service and everything that happened during
the night and finally accompanied by another day
of work in this hospital sao joão and
and there
and there it
is  because it is unprecedented and ready
the first signs of concern almost
of alarm one day it was my obligation
we joined rabbits and contribute with
my medical knowledge to be able to
citizenship the people today things seem
less somber public health conquest
that is a lot to conquer  at
the service the national health service to
respond
andthere
and there
and sabrina distance appeared there at the
post there you don't want to go
there to know mention in front
my opinion i think the
weber expeditionary is the puran cura mental a bomb
inside  mia undoubtedly let's be
professionals and with serious problems
that's what the person is
and then
and there
we can save lives we are facing
a virus  s that is a viru destroyer
of health systems I am supporting
health activities at different levels,
namely in what is
health planning is one of the characteristics of
public health and planning what are the
next steps to take in the academy this
balance between  they are from the outbreak the
racing contact and also or the measures
that are stopping in a way life
as we know it is
and after orly nail polishes
i can
and then
the most beautiful street a
and
then one more day of work finished it
's time  to change uniforms
and things here at the hospital continued, there
was some attention but at the same time
with some calm we are being
able to respond to this pandemic and if
we are able the answer here in the port
in the biggest hospital in porto is not
sao joão we will also be  able to do
all over the country and